simple concept you want to get money off
of someone else but they're going to say
look if you want to hold on to my money
and be able to have the privilege of
using it then i'm going to charge you
for it okay so this is simple interest
and you should recognize this formula
here okay there's two that work together
and they look very very similar and you
can tell me
which one you use
and why
okay so this is actually the first one
that you learn right let's just rehearse
what are these bits and pieces i stands
for
interest how much additional you
actually have to pay p stands for
principal which in this case you might
want to tag it as such right in this
case is the amount that you are
borrowing okay you mustn't confuse how
much you borrow versus how much you
repay all those kinds of things right so
this is the amount borrowed
okay r stands for
rate and n for
number of time periods okay now that
might be number of years number of
months number of days you've got to pay
attention to the question and see what
it gives you number of
time periods which is why
some of you may have learned
i equals prt instead of n because it's
time
all right now look carefully at the
difference between these two there's not
much of a difference
can you tell me when would i use this
one versus this one any suggestions your
heads up
so what is the difference between them
not a trick question
there's just that division by a hundred
okay so in what case would i need to
either divide by a hundred or not divide
by a hundred in order to make sure i get
the right number out
yeah but the bottom one be when you're
looking for like the overall percentage
of something okay excellent so so it
really depends on this guy here
right now if we have him as a percentage
this is what we're going to use
okay so if for instance the question
says to you as this one does five
thousand dollars six point seven percent
right so interest is a percentage
6.7
okay in order to work out what you're
going to get out at the end read through
your calculator let's just quickly
crunch through this i
didn't get my calculator
and see what happens
if you're using our top formula here
okay all you have to do is take your
three numbers amount being borrowed with
the rate and how long it's in there and
all you have to do is multiply out right
so they're laid out for you five
thousand six point seven
four years go ahead multiply it out
let's see what we get
okay
so
having used wrong color having used this
first formula
remember i borrowed five grand right the
number it spits out at me
is
134
000
okay so clearly something has gone wrong
because the amount of interest of being
charged is not even comparable to the
amount that we actually borrow right so
i shouldn't have used this i should have
used this one
which gives us
340. looks a little more reasonable okay
so in what case see if we can answer the
question again right
if this is the case that i use
this formula what case should i use this
one
if i don't have it as a percentage what
else might i have it out as a decimal
very good so for six point seven percent
the equivalent decimal would be
point zero six seven
right decimal form percentage form okay
for what it's worth and this is the
reason why the textbook quotes you this
okay um you're going to see this kind of
scenario all the time you'll get given
the percentage okay so you'll need to
divide by 100 and if you don't you'll
clearly see that your answer is
nonsensical okay you're right with that
cool
hold on when you say when you put in a
percentage so like normally i would go
to 6.7 percent i'll show you use your
percent button on your calculator yeah
that's fine because because the percent
button on your calculator right what
does it do it's per
per
cent hundred so all it's the percent
button divide by a hundred so
essentially you're including that part
within the formula so that's fine um
old-timey calculators like mine
don't have a percent button so i'm not
gonna do that okay so if you have one
that's fine
all right good question any other
questions
all right very quickly i'm gonna run you
through
three two more really quick examples you
can see the example we just worked out
right we were looking for the interest
that's what got us to be calculated okay
in practice all the the only other
things you get asked to work out are
okay what's the rate instead they'll ask
you to give a percentage right or what's
the term what's the value of m okay so
you just get slightly different numbers
you put them into the right spot and
then you solve just like we did and
that's all okay
let's quickly scroll down keep
forgetting i have a mouse here let's
have a look at this
question can you read that 2a can you
squirt
i'll put the i'll put the numbers over
on the left hand side so you can follow
me okay
and so i've got this
this is 2 a ok same scenario we're still
working out interest but there's a
little bit of a catch you guys have seen
this before but i want to remind you of
how to deal with it
here's the principle 5600
the rate is 13 percent
then the amount of time is 16 months
okay
however the interest rate doesn't match
right the interest rate is per
annum which is per year and then they've
given you a number of months right so
how am i going to convert this and then
able to
work out what my n actually should be
i'll start with 16 because that's how
many months there are but it's not 16
years so i should
divide
by 12 because that's how many months
there are in a year right so now i mean
you can see this is going to be one
whole year and 4 over 12 which is a
third one in the third years that makes
sense doesn't it that's how many years
i'm going to calculate so now i can work
it out just like i did before okay i
guess using this i'd use this formula
and you can crunch out a number from
there is that right
cool as i said all they'll do apart from
this is just rearrange things
instead of giving you p r and n and ask
for interest
they'll give you i
p and r and they'll ask for the term of
the loan or they'll ask some other thing
you always have three pieces and have to
work out the fourth okay